how much do you understand the control
involved in the landing how difficult is
that problem I couldn't tell you a
single thing about like the code and
like the avionics behind it but I can
tell you all the hardware that makes it
happen if that helps well that yeah I
mean to me it seems like whenever I talk
to people they they say it's not
that big of a deal in terms of the the
level of intelligence and the control
but to me it's just like when you
observe it
it seems incredible because of all the
variables evolved all the uncertainties
involved all the
um because there's aerodynamics I mean
like there's at different temperatures
there's so so much going on with the
fuel the burning of the the combustion
just everything that's going on to be
able to do perform control at such high
stakes effectively like you know that
code is probably not written in
JavaScript I guess is what I'm saying
actually no I don't it if I remember I
again this is well outside of my domain
um but
um they've coded in a Common Language
it's it's uh that's probably it's
probably going to be c yeah I'm pretty
sure it is and that was one of the
things that was weird is that Elon when
he you know started SpaceX was like
we're just going to code in the most
common language so that we don't have to
like have people learn this archaic you
know weird thing we can just literally
pull people off the streets and be like
here write it you know and that's
probably C plus plus I mean it'd be epic
if it was like python or something but I
don't I I think like reliable systems
have to be written in CC plus plus
probably which is a common language
which is something uh I imagine like
NASA Engineers would probably have to
use some kind of proprietary language in
the in the olden days for for security
for privacy all that kind of stuff oh
and the old old days like yeah those are
inventing Yeah the code and language
from scratch
uh for sure it was still it's just still
incredible that it's able to do that
like just the feat of engineering
involved is just it's truly
it's like one of the Marvels to observe
about these Rockets coming back to Earth
uh that they're able to land like the
drama of it is just incredible to see
yeah well the one of the fun things to
remember too with specifically with the
Falcon 9 and the Falcon 9 or Falcon
heavy boosters I mean it's the same
thing basically
um they shut down all but one of the
nine engines and even with that one
engine at its minimum throttle setting
it's still too much thrust to hover
so as this Rocket's coming down
if they start a little bit too early if
they light that engine too early it will
actually stop above the ground and will
not be able to lower itself it will
literally stop like say and say stop 200
feet above the ground
their only option is to kill the engine
and then it's just going to fall those
200 feet so they it's what we call like
a suicide burner a hover slam kind of
interchangeable terms because your
thrust to weight ratio is never below
one so they have to actually literally
be riding the throttle so what you do is
you kind of start ideally you know you
kind of start like in the middle of your
window of of throttle range so let's
pretend your engine can throttle down to
40 of its maximum rated thrust you might
start at like 70 percent of thrust in
the middle of that like window of where
it could burn so that so if all of a
sudden it's kind of coming in too hot
you have room to throttle up if you're
coming into you're actually you know a
little too early you throttle it down
you have a little bit of wiggle room
it's just amazing how smoothly and how
perfectly they're able to still control
that thing even though they're down to
one engine out of the nine and they're
still riding like the finest margin of
what's possible and they're continually
playing with that to try to get it
because every every bit of fuel they're
using and propellant they're using to
land is repellent they weren't using to
put something into space yeah so they
want that to be as efficient as possible
they're really like watching them hone
that in and and just continue to evolve
it and edit that and just get it to be
the Workhorse we're coming up on a
hundred consecutive Landings perfect
Landings 100 I think they've done like
150 something Landings altogether 160
altogether but we're talking like in a
row without blowing up which you know
five years ago was completely
experimental and insane and now we're
coming up to the point where we're 100
in a row it's like this is becoming more
reliable in the landing which is not the
primary Mission this is purely for
spacex's like gain is to recover the
booster it has nothing to do with the
effect of getting the payload on orbit
you know most of the time and the
landing is really only for their their
benefit and their gain long-term gain
like it's a long-term investment in in
being able to recover the the boosters